do you think eddie murphy will ever um
be able to go on netflix he'd have to
spend a year or two in clubs i guess
getting his act together and getting
warmed up again
because he keeps saying he's going to go
back to stand up i don't believe it
he keeps saying it about a year ago
when i was pl i was i was supposed to be
on tour right now
and when i was trying to lock up
buildings
eddie already had buildings some of
those buildings locked up
so it was like i don't want to take the
garden 20 days after eddie murphy
you know what i mean like yeah i don't
want it i don't i don't want
you know if any if you know if we were
boxers i don't want any parts of that
fight
yeah if you had eddie murphy on
yesterday i wouldn't come on today
let that simmer down he's smart
maybe he'll do it but i don't think it
would take him a long time i think it
would take him like a month or something
because i i've been to his house and
talked to him he's pretty funny he's
pretty
you know he's the most talented guy to
ever do it honestly
is that because he's got so many tools
in his arsenal like
he can do those impressions he can tell
a joke
he can tell stories he's just got so
many [ __ ] tools he could tell a
dirty joke like nobody's business like
most comedians wait to the
end of their specials to tell the dirty
jokes eddie murphy opens with the dirty
joke like he's that [ __ ]
he's so good like you know i mean like
like who the [ __ ] does that no one has
ever done that eddie murphy has that
attitude like i'm gonna open with the
dirty [ __ ]
and i'm still gonna [ __ ] slay you
i mean his best thing is probably the
ice cream man yeah i mean
and that's like and that's like a clean
ass
story that jerry or cosby could have
done
it's it's a masterpiece
[Applause]
the ice cream and it's coming it's sweet
it's it's really black too it's really
like urban
but it's right everyone can relate to it
you know like
hey ma throw down some money the ice
cream man is here that is like a
that is such an urban experience
throw down some money from the apartment
because we don't have ice cream in our
[ __ ] houses because we're [ __ ]
poor